the title of this talk is SPG can do
that part of the reason why I'm giving
this talk is because SVG as a graphics
format is just capable of so much and I
think we're just at the tip of the
iceberg for really touching on all of
those capabilities so yeah like I said
my name is Sarah dresser this is a photo
of me as a child and my mom and my
relationship with Authority I'm a senior
developer advocate at Microsoft I just
started so that's exciting and I just
think SVG is a total party you can kind
of make your party yourself or you can
have JavaScript be the event coordinator
get it event okay there's gonna be lots
of bad jokes where that came from
and we can do so many cool things with
it so some of you already might know the
benefits of SVG but just in case you
don't let's go over some of those it's
crisp on any display it's built with
math so basically any time you're making
an SVG you're just plotting a few
coordinates and the computer is drawing
all those coordinates out for you so
it's not like bitmaps where you know if
you make something really big or really
small it loses clarity and it kind of
loses pieces of it so that's really nice
it has less less HD I always mess that
part of it at less HTTP requests to
handle did it alright cool
it can have no age to be a request to
handle because you can have it directly
in line unlike other images where you
have to make requests from other sources
as we move into HTTP 2 this is less of
an issue but we're not quite there yet
so for the time being SVG is really
awesome for that it's easily scalable
for responsive one of my favorite things
it's in the name scalable vector
graphics that means that you can make it
adjust to any kind of viewport and well
definitely going to be doing stuff with
that today it's a really small file size
if you design for performance if you
design for performance is an important
part of that so we'll talk about that
today as well it's easy to animate again
one of my favorite things I wrote a
literal book of us hat it has a
navigable Dom which means that you can
reach right inside of it
move certain pieces around so if you
have a flat image where everything is
just kind of presented in front of you
in order to make an arm move or
something you'd have to go in and cut
out pieces of it in order to you know
kind of move them around these are
literally just Dom nodes that you can
slap classes on that you can do all of
the same things that you do with HTML
elements with so that's really cool we
talked about how it's and now it has a
navigable Dom it also can be accessible
because it has a navigable DOM and it's
fun remember when we used to have fun
fun's cool yeah cool all right so with
all of the Pens that I'm going to be
showing today I made all of these demos
but I'm gonna be showing you some work
that other people made as well to kind
of showcase them but I'll definitely
have their names at the top of them and
then also I make the slides open source
so you can check them out later SVG is
such a flexible medium we can do so much
with it we can manage state even with
within it and do all sorts of beautiful
effects so I actually hope that this is
the last year I have to show this slide
people think that SVG is really not well
supported because years past it wasn't
but look at all that green
we got Opera Mini we never get off from
Annie that's just amazing and you know
it says ie 11 there but it actually goes
back to ie 9 with partial support on ie
8 I don't know why can I use doesn't
show you all of that information but if
you're not using SVG because you think
it's poorly supported you can update
that information in your mind as well so
what does the scalable mean when we talk
about scalable vector graphics you can
see here we place the graphic directly
inline in the HTML and has width and
height attributes which keep it to that
size but then when I take those out it
adjusts and it fills that entire area
which means that if I wanted to you know
make it constrain to the viewport width
or the viewport height I can do so or if
I want to put it inside of a flex box or
grid or percentage you name it so that's
really nice because everything stays
totally consistent
and is positioning in CSS keeping you
down sometimes it but it kind of bothers
me SVG might just be your answer you saw
all of those things that were inside of
the SVG we're staying exactly at their
coordinates no matter what we were doing
to it that's really awesome for
positioning you can kind of just throw
all of the like crazy CSS stuff to the
wayside and position things within
SVG it even has text as a side note I
did this to myself on the plane on the
way here I was drinking wine and
watching a horror movie and splashed it
in my face anyway
SVG allows you to do create create
advanced effects like this type lock up
and it can look really slick and
professional while still using actual
accessible text that's so nice for
Responsive which also means that in
terms of animation we can create
something that's fully responsible and
scalable in every direction and the
animation values are working within that
coordinate system so they'll stay
totally sits totally stable even if
you're changing the sizes of him and
moving things around and adjusting it
these type of positioning refinements
are really really wonderful if you have
a ton of information on smaller screens
like mobile and you don't want to show
all of the information at once if you
have tons of icons and you need to kind
of collapse that view you can do really
advanced layout effects where you're
showing and hiding that information with
only a small amount of kilobytes so it
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
squishy either we don't just squish
things back and forth when we make
responsive design let's do some real
responsive design so I made a huggy
lazer Panda factory because you know we
need to know where huggy laser pandas
come from and that's where they come
from so if we have the huggy laser panda
on desktop we it's actually comprised of
three different SVG's we've got one for
the top part and one for the side and
one for the other side and then on
mobile they're going to stack and
reconfigure you can see that middle part
that one on the side that's magenta is
actually just being transformed
translated and kind of moving over to
the side
so if we have the Panda factory running
we have our Panda getting painted to be
a panda then we have our panda getting
lasered and then we have our Panda
getting hug heed you know like you have
in real life and then when we scale it
down to mobile everything can kind of
reconfigure and reconfirm and all of
this works on old Android Android
devices old windows phones and it's only
13 kilobytes so if we look into the code
here what we'll actually see is that I
have a timeline that's wrapped in a
function that's named appropriately in
case in this case the naming it
appropriately is like function paint
Panda and I I really literally have a
click event listener to reach rigor that
time line but you'll see all of the
functions are scoped to the SVG's itself
so the design and the functions are all
organized in the same way so if I need
to update something everything stays
totally organized we can also use that
stability for page transforms so react
is really awesome because it helps us
manage state in a really responsible
manner I made this with react and green
sock what green sock has an animation
API react coordinates the state while
green sock coordinates all of the
intermediary values so we're showing the
transition from page to page and all SVG
will stabilize all of our graphics while
we do so so in this example I have this
concept of screens
I'm toggling the screens forward and
then they wrap back around to the to the
beginning screen and then we have a
timeline function that can choreograph
all of the animation but something
that's really cool about the green sock
animation API is this thing called SVG
origin here or this thing called clear
props here the clear props will actually
allow us to remove any inline styles
that are set on that element or that Dom
ref so I can remove those if we need to
recalculate values or put it into
another position so here's another one I
made with view and next which I love
view is a front-end framework that is
very similar to react in that it's the V
of MVC you probably are familiar with it
next is our
quick and easy way to get server-side
rendering with view and it allows you to
do routing and all sorts of code
splitting without stepping outside of a
view file and because we're using SVG
for all of these animations everything
States totally stable Nucks
also gives us page transition hooks so
we can hook into the animation and make
it different per page so all the ways
that the mountains are changing and the
text is changing changes per page so if
you'd like to check out the code I have
a repo for it and also a demo site that
you that's live that you can check out
too I'm showing the slide so you can get
a sense of how those j/s hooks work we
have these different page routes and if
you want to plug into them there's a
bunch of different page hooks per page
the one that's really important here is
this transition mode and that's super
cool because when you have a transition
mode in view what it will do is it'll
allow that component to completely
unmount but it'll wait for the animation
to fully fade-out then it will unmount
and the other thing will wait until it's
done so you don't have to write any like
messy callbacks which is what you
usually end up having to do when you
write that kind of code so this is from
code drops it's a similar concept but
it's built in a different way the fixed
content lies beneath and once we move
the content up it gets revealed and all
at the same time that SVG path is
changed through path data ID and this is
done with animate is not green sock this
pen by Sullivan Nolan uses transitioning
effects and morphing this is back to
green socks morph SVG and you can see
how it's really captivating and again
because we're using SVG stays totally
stable for mobile but we can also use
SVG for the layout itself when we were
making this page for web animation
workshops our branding is all these
triangles so we wanted to make some
interesting page layouts those little
triangles between the sections are
little pieces of SVG where we've said
preserve aspect ratio none which means
that it's always gonna scale in every
direction with the container so usually
you don't want that right if it's like a
face or something we don't want that
and that's a technical term for that but
in terms of page layout that's exactly
what we want
cool so SVG can also be super tiny if
you look at this HP archive graphic it's
a breakdown of all of what we're
transmitting over the web right all of
the kind of content breakdown so we've
got a bunch of video we've got a bunch
of fonts and scripts and stylesheets but
images is huge images is 2/3 of what we
deliver over the internet for everybody
so I love this quote you can't be a web
performance expert without being an
image expert it's actually pretty true
if you think about it if you think about
that last graphic if you're not thinking
about the size of your graphics then
you're really doing yourself a
disservice I was asked to I used to be a
consultant before I worked for Microsoft
and this company hired me because they
had ten page ten second page load times
and just by optimizing the SVG's on
their site
I brought the the site speed down to
less than two seconds that's all of
those seconds of deployment and
performance all came from the graphics
so how did I do that
well not all SVG graphics are created
equal we have everything drawn with math
but if you have tons and tons of path
points and you're not not optimizing
correctly it can really bulk your files
so I really like using SVG oMG again
these are like linked up in the slides
if you want to check them out later
SVG oMG is by Jake Archibald it uses a
lot of service workers so if you have a
bunch of settings in it it will remember
the next time you go there which i think
is super cool it uses SVG oh the last
one under the hood which is terminal
based so if you're more comfortable with
your terminal you can use SVG oh but I
suggest you pair it with SVG oh GUI
because the way that you optimize
actually affects the way that that SVG
will look the middle one is Peter Colin
ridges SVG editor it's like a 15 year
old rails app that I just keep in there
cuz like I'm a neckbeard and I like it
still probably a little less useful but
really really still kind of fun I also
wrote a post for CSS tricks called
high-performance SVG's that was
all of the process that I went through
to reduce the size of those SVG's for
that consulting gig so in this pen I
have this little draggable thing and
it's a little spaceman and he's standing
on the moon and the cow keeps scaring
him as he goes over the moon and it's
touch enabled for mobile and that whole
SVG is 2 kilobytes so you can do really
kind of cool effects and you know show
really really information interesting
information and have things be super
small so while we're looking at this
let's take a gander at what's happening
under the hood because I ran into a
gotcha when I was trying to build this
so at first I was like oh okay I'm gonna
make this like thing that's like a null
object you know around with this cow and
I can spin that and it can also detect
if there are collisions with like get
pout and get bounding client wrecked or
get B box for that little astronaut head
but then it was firing all the time and
I was like what's going on I think the
browser is wrong no the browser is not
wrong what was happening once I started
you know putting like you know borders
around it and kind of understanding of
this a little bit more is that the
browser doesn't see diagonals the
browser only sees in rectangles so to
give you a better idea of what that
means if you look at the bounding box
stroke of these rotating elements this
is what the Dom sees so I just think
that's crazy like look at that circle
that's so weird so sometimes in order to
debug things like this you do actually
have to think like the browser not like
yourself okay back to the laid of SVG's
because there they have the potential to
be so small SVG is the perfect time to
use something like a loader a lot of
loaders are really ugly and a lot of
loaders are using gifts which are really
heavy if you have a heavy and ugly gift
maybe you should think about updating it
this graphic when I was given this given
this graphic by the designer this is for
smashing magazines checkout experience
it was 35 kilobytes and I brought it
down to 6 kilobytes just by optimizing
it correctly and that includes the
animation and everything
so SVG's can make other graphics smaller
there's this thing called SVG JPEG SVG
and by this guy named Shah and this is
not like a particular graphic that I
found but you can see that just dropping
in any graphic that I had around which
is my I am happy Marge Simpson you know
we brought the file size from 38
kilobytes to 16 kilobytes just by
switching it to an SVG and creating an
image mask over the kind of repeated you
know images if a bit mask has a lot of
the same colored squares it's still
mapping out all of that territory where
an SVG can say like take the bounds of
these things and don't paint them just
show this one color so that's pretty
cool
SVG can be accessible we mentioned this
before there's actually like a ton of
ways that SVG can be accessible and it's
like can be kind of complicated but nine
times out of ten this is what you're
gonna need in order to make an SVG
accessible so I'm just gonna dive into
that really quick so we write Aria
labeled by and then a title and that
title it has to be the first thing that
follows that SVG tag that title also has
to have a unique ID on it otherwise it
won't be picked up by jaws and in Nvidia
devices just writing title is not enough
we also have roll of presentation on the
SVG itself what that'll do even for your
icons you should be doing this it'll
allow it and screen readers to know that
it's an image and not announce
everything inside if you want it to
announce things inside you move that to
roll group so that's some of the ways
that you can make it responsive I also
like writing Lang you know whatever
language it is so that you know
somebody's using a screen reader in
another language the computer does the
hard work for them that's pretty cool so
there's a resource with support charts
there's also this article by Heather
that she wrote for CSS tricks she spent
like every weekend going to the library
checking every different device this
whole big labor of love for the
community so definitely check out that
article she did a great job with it SVG
can be styled like text this is kind of
like
not too fancy but something that you a
lot of people kind of come to me and ask
me about so let's cover it real quick
someone on Twitter asked me about this
they made an SVG sprite sheet and
they're not styling it along with the
text they wanted everything you know if
they change that line of text for it to
pick that up so really so this is the
question code I left it exactly how it
was and the secret trick here that you
may or may not know about is that you
change the fill to current color camel
cased and that will just make it reflect
whatever it is so right now I just have
that line with a class that says color
red on it and it's picking up that color
so if you are using SVG icons for your
site that's a really quick way to not
have a headache whenever you're working
with it SVG can bounce we can make a
ball bounce with SVG really easily
without any Lant animation libraries
using a requestanimationframe if we have
this bounce ball bouncing we can use a
little physics to kind of drum up the
bounce of the ball and we can make the
radius bigger and we can do all of that
midstream so I'm using view again here
and there's some info that I'm not sure
showing here but here's the gist of it
we've got data we've got the total like
height of everything we've got the
radius we're incrementing things based
off of a quick event and then we're we
have gravity that increases the vertical
speed horizontal speed increments from
the horizontal position all of these
things I learned from like just pulling
things out of physics books so you don't
have to invent all of this stuff from
scratch you can steal ideas that have
been around for a really long time this
pen by Tiffany ray side is one of my
favorite animations of all time she's
not using any library or anything at all
she's spinning up pieces of the SVG
applying physics and even these like
crazy bounces to to it all so she
manipulates the SVG path values when it
hits the wall she's just kind of a
master so if you don't already follow
her on Twitter a code pen you should
definitely go do that
SVG can snap in order to create some you
know really really beautiful effects
we're gonna use some es6 template
template literals which you're probably
all familiar with
but just in case you aren't I'm just
gonna say something about them really
quickly previously we had string
concatenation and all of that printed
out to this which was really hard to
read and it was kind of ugly and it was
kind of error-prone because it was hard
to read and now we have awesome template
literals that when you put things in
backticks we can just manipulate strings
really really readily and what does that
have to do with SVG well SVG all of
those paths in sight in Venice Fiji are
really just a bunch of strings of
commands and they have these curve
values and all of the letters mean a
certain thing and draw a certain kind of
curves and create certain kind of paths
so I really like this kind of path
Explorer tool if you're not familiar
with the way that SVG works you can go
and play with this I also wrote about it
in my book if you want to you know
something that's a little bit more
traditional and if we know enough about
how those curves are made updating them
is very simple with something like
template literals when we're building
out these paths we start with a move -
and then we can create those curves by
using things like C and Q so we give it
a handle and then we give it another
point and the computer draws a curve for
us how cool is that
you can like plot three points and the
computer draws a curve I just think
that's great
so that's really neat and then we can
plot the points we have a bunch of
different coordinate values that were
updating and it's so flexible we can
make effects like this
so you might have noticed that that SPG
was distorting at the end there so let's
kind of cover distortion really quickly
and big and how you can do that
so distortion filters are really awesome
there was this great code code drops
demo with a bunch of buttons and
definitely the most you know impressive
technique was you hit a button and this
little ripple effect came out and what
they're doing in order to create that is
they're using a filter called turbulence
and you can animate this filter in
JavaScript you can't do it in CSS it's
not an anime table property we're kind
of like hacking the spec here and
manipulating it because there's just a
bunch of numbers but I would say that
from manipulating filters and pushing
the doms boundaries and stuff and doing
things I'm not supposed to do I would
suggest setting the filter on a timer
like applying it when you need it and
taking it off when you don't because it
is performance and sensitive it's not
really hardware accelerated so we can
make things like this pool and that's
pretty fun because the way that this is
done is by applying that filter and
using an image to distort anything
that's beneath it so we can have tons
and tons of path values like you see
here everything under the pool is also
getting updated too and we can do it
really really simply all we're doing is
we're taking that distortion filter in
that image and we're basically making it
scale down hit the wall and scaling up
and we're also animating the filter
so we can do like really really crazy
effects and when I made this pan I
wasn't really thinking about like the
political climate so it's a weird one to
show but we can by animating filters we
can also make things like a realistic
candle that's drawn with math that's
really really fun in order to make this
I have a few different pieces that I
just kind of traced off of a candle
photo so I just made this in Illustrator
and then made a gradient that's attached
to it and then I they're not actually
blue but I have a bunch of different
path values that I'm going to set on a
for loop and I'm gonna morph between
those path values for each second and
plot them along a timeline but I also am
using a filter and it's this gooey
filter that Lucas beber created so he
has some prior art here he's actually
using this with divs you can make an SVG
filter and apply it to HTML you don't
only have to use SVG so that's pretty
cool so a lot of people use this kind of
GUI effect it's a blur filter in a
contrast filter applied at the same time
so yeah we cannot because you know that
standard deviation of the filter is just
using numbers we can have JavaScript
update those numbers
requestanimationframe knows how to
update numbers so we can do that we go
through all of the path values and then
we've got a little math dot random
opacity because nature is just a little
unpredictable and then we can use that
effect to create smoke with math SVG can
do on the fly logo adjustment this demo
was made by leav aroo-whoo if you don't
follow her already
you should probably go do so because she
makes all sorts of crazy great things
but basically you're allowed to update
these logos on the fly which i think is
super great if you have to collaborate
with a designer it keeps on not making
their mind up and you're like they're
like Oh change it out here oh no it like
fat is in oh no flat is in you can kind
of make all of these things really
really adjustable so you don't have to
keep changing things up and she made
this with a tool called maava that she
built that's basically so that
you can drum up sites using HTML and CSS
with very little JavaScript which is not
very useful for us but I'm pretty sure
that almost everyone in this audience
has a family member that's like hey can
you make me a website and if you do this
is a really good thing to show them
because they with just a little bit of
training they can make their own website
and you can get on to your real life
work
SVG can draw itself too so let's say we
have a shape and that's the stroke of
that shape is dashed but we make the
dash all the way around that entire
shape it's the length of the entire
shape that offset the offset between
those two dashes is animatable so we can
have an SVG draw all onto the page just
using CSS or something so I made this
pen to kind of celebrate New Year's and
there's like you know the fireworks are
that kind of idea and pew and yeah
that's this pen by Chris Gannon is also
really awesome he does this that same
effects if you don't follow him you
should go follow him because he I think
he's just pretty much a genius he's also
doing this with clip paths it's super
cool you can also interact with an SVG
we can manipulate it and interact with
it on the fly as well so if since it has
a navigable navigable Dom you can do all
sorts of things with it again I'm using
view here to like update the text and
make random lines and allow the user to
kind of play with the SVG graphic as
much as they want to I can also animate
it if I want to and have them be in
charge of that as well and I made this
demo too long so we're all gonna watch
it so it's gonna play the animation but
the coolest part of all of this is I'm
gonna play this animation it's still a
graphic so I can still download it and
it's going to respect all of the
positions that were set during that
animation so even though I'm animating
it it's still in all of
those places it's still a graphic that
they can hand out to their friends or
something so here inside the HTML
template we can create some semantic
form elements and then we can bind them
to these methods where we're creating
and kind of drumming up pieces of the
SVG on the fly we use s we can use SVG
to respond to things that the problem
that the browser is doing so we have
this like little Wally pen I don't know
if you've seen the movie Wally but I
really like it he has a little cockroach
friend and he's you know kind of
reaching out for him every time the user
moves across the page so what we have
here and we have a bit more code than
that but basically we have these at
Mouse move events and I've created an
entire timeline for him reaching his
arms out complete with eases and then I
plot that along that progress of the
timeline along with the coordinate so
the user can control all of that and it
stays really really lifelike so in order
to make that pen we had to clip and mask
things so SVG can clip and mask things
SVG offers this thing called clip path
which is really nice because if you
looked at his arms they had to kind of
reach out from somewhere right I can't
just keep tucking everything behind over
everything else in order to make it look
realistic it has to clip out parts of
his arm so we were able to do that with
clip path and if you use something
called mask you can use opacity so clip
paths will just kind of respect the
geometry but something like a mask we
can create something with an you know
like a gif masking with all of these SVG
patterns and you know slowly unveil them
we create a mask and F's
and and put inside of it the image that
we want to use and then we have we apply
it to a rect that also has a pattern
associated with it so I learned this
technique from yolks 'el who has like a
whole bunch of pens like this that are
super super awesome she also has the
most comprehensive you know collection
of SVG and CSS clip paths so if you need
to learn about them or you're confused
about them this is all like interactive
and you can play with it and the code is
open source I also kept getting confused
between
between clip paths and masks so I wrote
a CSS tricks article that you can look
at - that defines the differences
between them CSS has tricks has pretty
good SEO so I knew I could just go look
at my own resource again and again if I
got confused again
and since SVG also has text you can have
that clip that masking applied a text
and do things like have your users
update text to this pen by Knoll Delgado
is probably the most famous and also my
favorite example of this clipping and
masking that's paired with animation SVG
can signify something changing so I kept
going in between different time zones
for my work and I you know couldn't
remember where all my co-workers were
what time it was and I could have just
made a dial that just showed what time
things were but by changing the SVG and
making that dial that associates that
change in time I get a better sense of
whether or not it's day or night and I
can ping them or not and they're
probably with their kids or something
like that but while I was working on
this something interesting I found was I
used to use this thing called moment
jeaious that kind of allowed me to work
with time data and understand where
everybody was you know in terms of like
daylight savings time but there's
actually a native method called - local
time string that offers all of these
defaults like hours and minutes and all
sorts of things so that actually
respects all of those daylight savings
time so you can eliminate a big library
like moment you can use SVG's view box
as a camera this is one of my favorites
you might already know this but when you
have something like a graphic when SVG
is plotting all of those points to draw
those coordinates it's doing so on a big
piece of graph paper basically and that
piece of graph paper is endless it's
just this giant coordinate system and in
order to see inside of that SVG and know
where to plot those coordinates and what
you're looking at you have a thing
called a view box and the view box is
made up of 4 values 0 0 that's x and y
where to start it off and then width and
height so if I wanted to update this
view box to just look at these little
houses
or something I would have to you know
update them to 215 1 by 160 42 by 20 so
SVG also has a native method called get
bee box and that will return this object
that has X Y width and height for
anything that's inside the SVG that's
cool that sounds a little familiar that
might be what we need to maybe animate
it or you know update it on the fly so
here I'm just you know using that to
update the view box and then if I take
that out it will go right back to where
it was so I'm just setting the
attributes based on that so then we can
do something like this data
visualization where we're zooming in on
a certain country in order to show
different pieces of information and
again because it's SVG it's all totally
scalable for mobile and it's so small
because it's just one path that's drawn
we can also make a flowchart I'm
basically this is just a giant SVG and
we're just like moving things based on
the user input and like then people can
pick a certain thing and then they can
go to you know a different kind of
output so we can make you know
interactive flowcharts this one is
really cool this is like a game that
somebody made updating the view box
where they're like placing little
household items and stuff but we can do
better we can do like a big game so so
let's make a game and that will be the
last thing we do this afternoon so if we
have a game about a hipster elephant
that's going to go get tacos but his
friends keep texting him to change plans
and you're supposed to try to go get the
tacos but avoid the text messages and
like there's margaritas for extra bonus
points
oops so you can basically move this guy
around and like your heart meter goes up
and down and if you lose the game you
become hangry and you have to watch a
movie you already saw and if you win the
game you could tweet out your score it's
based on real-life events so how do we
use SVG in order to create this we're
using react to manage all the state for
that application if you know
I'm in say for an application you can
probably already make a game too so
we're using SVG three ways we have it
directly inline in the HTML for loops we
have background images for things like
tacos we're not really you know updating
the tacos we're just kind of throwing
them across so they don't have to do
anything super special and we have
things that are in line directly in
react so let's look at that last one
really quickly so if we have this is a
slightly older pen so yes I know I'm
using react create class I wouldn't use
that now I would use class extends so if
we have the initial state of that score
that's at 500 and then you know we're
setting the game to start because they
can play it again they can you know get
to the end and decide to replay so we're
setting the score back to 500 if they do
so we don't want them to have too much
you know winning too much or losing too
much and then we have this update score
that will either like end the game or
win the game if it gets to a certain
amount but then and my highlighter is
not on this it's on the dots but it
should be on the heart meter and that
heart meter we're passing down this dot
state score so you might have noticed
that heart meter at the top of the at
the top of the game that was kind of
keeping track of our score so basically
we have this SVG and that SVG is
actually really really big because I
want to use whole numbers for this I
don't want to use like twenty seven
point two five or something to update
the score when he's a thousand or zero
so it's really big and then we have the
weights that's this stop prop score and
in our racks in SVG in order to update
it we have an X Y width and height just
like the bounding box so we can update
that on the fly and because it's SVG we
can make it super small then for the
size of the screen that we need and on
desktop it's a certain size and on
mobile it's a different size with media
queries all of that and we didn't even
get to any data visualization I wrote a
book about SVG animation this is not my
book this is my friend making fun of me
I don't have a man glove animal that's
not even my last name I do have a real
all right look I think I have like a
fancy chicken or something that's cool
yeah thank you so much for coming today
I appreciated
[Applause]